utiliza el método de completar el
cuadrado perfecto para que la siguiente
ecuación cuadrática ye igual a menos 3x
cuadrada más 24 x menos 27 tenga una
forma canónica y además identifica el
vértice y bueno nosotros ya sabemos que
es una forma canónica cuando tenemos una
ecuación cuadrática en forma canónica se
ve de la siguiente manera y es igual a a
x x
bent elevado al cuadrado ya esta
expresión le sumamos y esta es la forma
canónica de una ecuación cuadrática y
bueno ya que tengo la ecuación
cuadrática sabemos que podemos
identificar el vértice si hacemos x - b
igual a 0 es decir sólo lo que está
dentro del cuadrado si hacemos x menos b
igual a 0 voy a obtener que x igual a b
es el valor de x del punto del vértice y
por lo tanto todo esto lo quedaría que
es 0 y entonces me queda que es igual a
c y ese es el valor de y del punto del
vértice así que vamos a hacer lo vamos a
tomar esta ecuación déjame escribirla
aquí abajo y voy a intentar escribir la
de la forma canónica lo primero que
quiero que te des cuenta
la ecuación es completamente divisible
entre menos 3 alguien nos puso la trampa
de que esto se puede dividir
completamente entre menos 3 y entonces
se sacó como un factor común al menos 3
voy a obtener aa y me quedaría mucho
mejor tener en lugar de menos 3x
cuadrada simple y sencillamente tener x
cuadrada por lo tanto voy a factorizar
el menos 3 y me va a quedar menos 3 que
multiplica x cuadrado menos 8 x 24 entre
menos 3 me da menos 8 menos 8 x más 9
menos 27 entre menos 39 y esto bueno
espera espera voy a escribir aquí el 9
hasta acá porque voy a completar el
binomio cuadrado perfecto más 9 y
entonces ya tengo esta ecuación
cuadrática al menos ya tengo el valor de
amd y ahora lo que voy a hacer es sacar
el binomio al cuadrado perfecto para
esto me fijo en el coeficiente que tiene
la equis de la primera potencia que es
menos 8 este menos 8 recuerda que hay
que dividirlo entre 2 y después elevado
al cuadrado por lo tanto me queda menos
8 entre 2 es menos 4 al cuadrado humedad
16 entonces le estoy agregando 16 y date
cuenta que con esto ya obtengo el
binomio del cuadrado
esto es lo mismo que x menos cuatro
elevado al cuadrado pero esta ecuación
al agregarle 16 se desbalancea si yo lo
que quiero es balancear la de nuevo lo
que tengo que hacer es quitarle 16 para
que 16 menos 16 me dé 0 esto está
desbalanceado y recuerda que además
estoy multiplicando por el menos 3 y
entonces me va a quedar que la primera
parte de esta ecuación que tengo aquí x
cuadrada menos 8 x más 16 esto es lo
mismo que x menos 4 al cuadrado ya tengo
mi el binomio al cuadrado perfecto
entonces que me va a quedar si todo esto
que se poniendo demorado en el binomio
cuadrado perfecto si te das cuenta que
ya tengo el cuadrado del primero menos
dos veces el primero por el segundo más
el cuadrado del segundo que fue lo que
aumente pero además quité menos 16 por
lo tanto no le pasó nada raro a mi
ecuación y esto sigue equilibrado
entonces me quedan menos 3 que
multiplica a x menos cuatro elevado al
cuadrado recuerda que esto salió de
equis cuadrada menos 8x más 16 y después
tengo menos 16 más 9 lo cual me da menos
7 esto es mi ecuación cuadrática y ya
casi lo tengo de la forma canónica si te
das cuenta tenemos menos 3 que
multiplica
a un paréntesis pero también nos falta
distribuir este menos 3 para obtener
perfectamente mi forma canónica y me va
a quedar eso se queda igual y después me
queda menos 3 x menos 7 lo cual es más
21 y ya obtuve mi forma canónica de esta
ecuación cuadrática ahora lo que me pide
es que además identifica el vértice y
para identificar el vértice recuerda que
la parte de adentro de mi binomio al
cuadrado ya tengo que hacer igual a 0 es
decir tengo que tomarme x menos 4 igual
a cero voy a escribirlo y de aquí
obtengo que x es igual a 4 x es igual a
4 y entonces si esto se hace 0 esto de
aquí se va a ser 0 y ya me va a quedar
que es igual a 21 10 igual a 21 x es
igual a 4 y entonces este es el punto de
milberg de esta ecuación cuadrática a
ver vamos a graficar la tengo aquí me
deje de las yes este va a ser mi eje de
aries no voy a tomar por aquí a mi eje
de las x
y mi vértice está cuando x vale 4 voy a
suponer que estas cuatro ya vale 21 voy
a suponer que este es el valor de e
igual a 21 x james y entonces aquí tengo
el punto de mira vértice ahora la
pregunta es esta parábola abra hacia
abajo o abre hacia arriba es decir va
hacia arriba o hacia abajo y como no
puedo saber bueno lo primero que quiero
que te des cuenta es que esta parte que
tengo aquí esto de aquí es siempre
positivo porque tengo una expresión
elevada al cuadrado recuerda que todo lo
que elevó al cuadrado siempre es
positivo o es mayor o igual que 0 y a
una cosa mayor o igual que 0 si la
multiplicó por un número negativo es
decir por menos 3 voy a obtener que todo
esto que tengo aquí siempre me va a dar
valores negativos porque un positivo por
un negativo siempre me da un negativo es
decir un valor menor o igual a 0 y si a
esto le sumó 21 quiere decir varias
cosas primero que el valor más grande
que puede tener esta parábola es cuando
esta parte de rojo es igual a 0 cuando
esta parte de rojo es igual a cero me
queda mi vértice es decir mi máximo y a
partir de aquí le voy a ir quitando
dando cosas a 21 porque si a 21 le
agrego algo negativo se va a hacer cada
vez más pequeño y entonces la parábola
tiene que abrir hacia abajo porque estoy
obteniendo valores cada vez más pequeños
esto quiere decir que mi parábola va
hacia abajo o abre hacia abajo es de
esta forma voy a intentar la dibujarla
lo mejor posible y va a ser algo así
esta es mi parábola o el esposo en
parábola de esta ecuación cuadrática y
date cuenta que esto siempre pasa porque
aquí al lado tenemos un número negativo
tenemos el menos 3 si tuviésemos un
número positivo entonces esta parábola
abriría hacia arriba el valor de a es el
que me indica si abre hacia arriba o
hacia abajo mi parábola entonces este
vértice es un máximo porque el valor de
a es negativo si el valor de a fuera
positivo entonces mi parábola abriría
hacia arriba y el vértice sería un
mínimo